want your company to thrive never hire
anyone under 25. a recent survey finds
that three out of four managers agree
that gen Z employees those are born
after 1997 are harder to work with than
other Generations they're also too old
to have sex with said Leo DiCaprio
but in fact some get fired less than a
week after their start date you know
that happened to me once when I took a
smoke break at my job pumping gas
many blame the pandemic for stunting
their understanding of office etiquette
resulting in quote weird office Behavior
including poor communication skills and
an inability to conduct themselves in a
business setting that includes being on
their phones during meetings showing a
lack of effort and demanding special
perks even though they're new also I
hate it when they make eye contact in
the elevator
I'm trying to pee
but perhaps gen Z isn't totally to blame
as a conservative editor applied to the
New York Post Biden progressives and
liberal media are teaching them to be
depressed and fearful according to a
Harvard youth poll 54 of gen Z feel
nervous anxious or on edge 52 percent
have trouble relaxing 47 feel depressed
or hopeless quote if Democrats are
winning the war for the hearts and minds
of America's youth however the price of
Victory may be the poisoning of those
same hearts and Minds the party of Hope
and change has become the party of
Despair so given that mindset the real
surprise is that they're showing up for
work at all and when they do not a
single one of them will agree to shave
my back
Emily do you agree with this I mean is
it there for like imagine you're in a
generation where everybody tells you the
world's going to end in 12 years why
would you work hard
I guess but I think on campuses it's
being fostered and social media is such
a talk successful that they're not even
evolving past some young tiny nubile age
they don't have executive functioning
skills they don't have a prefrontal
cortex they are literally different
humans but what appalls me and also
terrifies me is that all of these things
are always put in the office setting
like they're triggered easily you know
they they take naps they don't make eye
contact they're not good communicators
but then in that article it talked about
in the medical field what is happening
and that is frightening there was a
physician in Arizona that talked about
how her residents were all gen Z she
said they literally are like I don't
really want to see patients not you know
I'm going to opt out today she said they
call her by her first name they don't
say like Dr Bill or Dr Lee whatever they
literally this will have an impact on us
we laugh now I'm laughing but in about
10 or 15 years when these guys are doing
our surgeries it's going to be
frightening back me up Kevin
I hire these people and what I've
learned is I've got you know investments
in 50 plus companies that are private
and we hire gen Z's all the time a third
of their careers so far in their lives
were done remotely so they don't know
office etiquette because they've never
done it particularly this last three
years and I'll give you an example I
think just sums it up I don't know if
it's good or bad but it's it's reality
we're interviewing a young woman
spectacular resume for a finance job and
you really want to hire slowly and fire
quickly that's what I've learned that's
how you manage a business you want to
make sure you're hiring the right team
member first interview fantastic second
interview really good starting to get
interested so I hadn't met her yet and I
want to meet everybody that she's coming
to the top operating company this is a
big gig so our HR woman calls her and
says okay now
um you're going to get your third
interview with Kevin O'Leary and she
goes I only do two I don't do three
no and I said go
hey
I mean that kind of arrogance yeah is
transphobe
I am so glad that I didn't hire that
beep
I mean I just that that is
unbelievable
I mean we invested in her we worked hard
to get no one wants to do multiple
interviews interviews are painful too
that that to me said okay yeah before we
start this again
at a little age difference now like
throw up extra three years let's get
somebody that's past 30. let's get
somebody who knows how this works
because I don't want to waste your time
and I certainly don't waste my time that
was
whoever worked with that person is a you
know high school they gave you those
coaches whatever it was guidance
counselors yeah like you know career
counselor
she didn't get one yeah she missed that
lottery I had one but he just touched me
a lot yes Chris do you see this in
comedy do you have young Comics that
that I feel entitled like they should
they should have a better uh slot on the
night than you and you because you've
been toiling for now 35 years Chris well
comedy is a good I know true comedies as
a woman comedy is is just took one Bud
Light comedy is is
um one of those things where it's like
you can play pretend you know yeah it's
just the audience doesn't care you have
the audience gives you one minute and
then even if Jerry Seinfeld walked up
there they're like oh it's Seinfeld but
then after that one or two minutes like
you need to be funny yeah and so if
that's the beauty about comedy is like
you can try to do this or do that or
stronghold but the audience will just be
like either you're funny or you're not
and that's what's beautiful about it but
in this world corporate world and just
the young you know gen Z people it's
becoming like I don't know like where is
Gen Z be just normal like here on the
western side you know countries they're
all like you know covet or whatever it's
like it's going to get to the point like
the only 25 year olds you can hire like
used to work for Isis yeah you know like
they're the best they're just normal
they're not they're so what they cut a
few heads off but at least they're not
going to do a tick tock and yes you know
in the office and me to me and they know
their gender yeah they just listen they
have you give them a room let them go
crazy with a lot a little bit and then
they're good they work they they come in
for the third interview they definitely
come in from the third interview Tom do
you uh do you see it correlate I mean a
link between uh how they're being taught
about how the environment is treating
them and how they be at work well uh
unlike Kevin I only own 48 companies
yeah so uh I don't have the same
experience but you know I used to be
like I used to think that that the Gen Z
was lazy and everything but after this
whole covert thing I mean I I'm starting
to side with them like they realize
these most of these jobs are stupid and
you know all these people who spent if
you spent two years at home on Zoom
you don't have a real job like you're a
jerk and like a gen Zer should take your
job because you're not doing anything
anyway they were all at home on zoom and
because you can't fix a toilet on Zoom
so the real blue collar people are all
doing their jobs and so these gen Z
people are realizing that any job where
you go and work in an office it's
probably dumb and if you know and you
shouldn't be doing it
I'm talking about blackface
save yourself
what do you think why do you do comedy
you don't want to work in a building
right yeah some dumb manager yeah but
even comedy at some point the chat GPT
can do it well you know what I mean like
exactly so all of these jobs are dumb so
all these gen Z people and they're
thinking like I have an app I can go
make my own living uh I'm sure Kevin
disagrees with me on this but I think
most jobs are stupid now and in the
future even the doctors like yeah I'm
not worried I'm gonna do my own surgery
yeah that's true
uh uh AI is going to be the new doctor
because you're going to plug stuff in
and you're like hey is this mole cancer
and because and you get all the
information from around the world and it
goes yes and then I'll give you a stat
you're gonna like because again with the
54 companies okay we made we made the
assumption that fifteen one five percent
would not return so we adjusted our real
estate holdings accordingly and we made
the assumptions it was the people in
accounting and Logistics and compliance
the desk jobs they're going to do it
from home
now we're out of the pandemic
55 percent won't come back yeah and a
half damn sales guys they're not coming
back salesmen why do I have to come back
to the office I'm selling I'm out here
selling yeah all the people that have
the rat pits in the basement those
little cubicles it doesn't matter what
their job was they're not coming back to
the rat pit that's it because they've
moved out of the city they don't want to
get killed on the way to work downtown
San Francisco war zone La war zone New
York death war zone like nobody wants to
do it that's true so you know I cannot
victimize anyone anymore it's so hard
all right we got to move on hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else